it's the first inter-governmental inna
goshi ated agreement on all aspects of
migration the UN migration pact more
than 190 states want to sign it but what
does the agreement actually say
increased information data collection is
one part migrants should be given
information about their chosen route and
they should be informed about the risks
people living in countries on the road
and in host countries should also be
informed about the consequences of
migration and to ensure that information
is based on facts authorities should
exchange data at an international level
the pact asks origin countries to work
towards eradicating poverty to create
jobs and to meet basic standards for
nutrition and education standards should
be set to protect those who nonetheless
decide to leave human rights have to be
respected the pact also encourages sea
rescues countries should make safe and
legal border crossings possible the pact
calls for more international cooperation
and the fight against people smuggling
networks the countries could for example
exchange information on smuggling routes
but not all countries agree with the
packet demands the u.s. was the first
country to announce it was not going to
sign hungry Australia Poland Israel
Austria and the Czech Republic have
already spoken out against adding their
signatures they criticize what they see
as a too positive view of migration and
say the pack could lead to an increase
in unwanted migration some countries
also argue the pack could affect the
border protection policies but what were
the countries have to do legally nothing
the contract is non-binding
the UN migration pact is more about
sending a political signal migration is
a global phenomenon and the
international community wants to tackle
it together